one of the central themes of
architectural history is the way in
which architecture relates to its own
representation whether this is through
visual material its conventions
orthography perspective or whether it is
through language I want to focus today
on a period in the late 18th century and
on a group of architects called the
visionary architects visionary because
not only did they rethink architectures
relationship to representation to words
and to images but also because they
began to invent utopia we're going to
look at the works of her to do and
especially of itchin we boules and what
eventually was called Oxitec job
outlawed or speaking architecture so I
want to begin here with one of these
visionary architects by the name of
Claude Nicola LeDoux he is someone who
was probably best known today for having
built the first modern Factory and this
Factory was conceived as a place to
manufacture salt in the late 18th
century and I want to start there
because I want to make a point about one
of the more curious aspects of 18th
century architecture today when we think
of the architectural process an
architect has an idea they set it down
on paper they will build a model they
move through a sequence of highly
conventionalized representations the
plan the section the elevation sometimes
they will come up with images that are
more perspectival that evoke somehow a
real through the image and lastly if
they're lucky the building gets built
one of the strange things about the late
18th century is that you'll see
architects reverse the process they will
go through the Commission they will
build a building and from the real they
will imagine a fictional architecture so
for example if we take the Salt Works
which today actually received the status
a world heritage monument through UNESCO
it exists it was built it functioned as
a factory in the late 18th and into the
19th century but what clued Nicola did
is that he took that Factory and he
imagined an ideal city he imagined a
utopia that he called the ideal city of
show so I want to grapple with this idea
in the late enlightenment but I want to
do so by going back in time and looking
at a broad range of examples and in fact
the tradition of the ideal city so let's
begin by looking at another book a book
that Ludo published in 1804 towards the
end of his life as a kind of opus to his
own work he entitled it architecture
considered in relation to the arts to
social mores and to legislation and in
this book you will find a map and a
perspectival view of the ideal city of
show that he extrapolated from his Salt
Works Factory now these are two
different visual strategies a map is
topographic the second is really a
bird's eye perspective as if we were
flying over the town and seeing it
unfold into the countryside but if we
compare them there are other differences
that strike us so when you look at the
map what you see is a highly geometric
configuration it's strongly felt in this
cartographic setting and the theatres of
production of the production of salt is
sitting right in the middle here in a
fully enclosed heavily circumscribed
oval it's as if the town were actually
fortified and in fact it is the ramparts
are indicated in the plan and even in
the legend we see that the salt works
are identified at the heart of it all we
learn from the list on the right the
insert here that a parish church appears
on the right to the left there's a Hall
of Justice
oval shape is so circumscribed that it
actually casts a shadow on the landscape
it's a highly paranoid configuration as
though to get into the city is an act of
enclosure so we have only two roads to
get in and out of town and the sense
that these roads are highly sort of a
diagrammatic we have one road running
north to south from the forest to the
river and then another running east-west
these are the only points of access into
the city of show however if you look at
the perspective of view the view
perspective done as you - oh you're
gonna see an entirely different kind of
experience here the topography unveils
and reveals mountains in the background
you'll see that there's a far more open
sense the ramparts are in fact gone and
and kind of integration of the landscape
with the town so the kind of stifling
geometric character of the map is
replaced by a far more open feel the
semicircle just like the map is sort of
fully elaborated into its elliptical
form but there's a far more seamless
movement between the center the focal
point the Saltworks
and the farms that dot the countryside
now what's clear in the view and less
clear in the map is that Ladue is
actually working out a design for public
space for rest publica and trying to
depict a harmonious living environment
so we see troops gathering onto the
Esplanade we see the factory smoke
rising out of the chimneys to sort of
indicate that production is happening in
a sense activities unfold here and
emphasize that life thrives as a result
of this ideal city and as a result also
of the proper exploitation of nature's
resources so when we look here it's the
buildings that speak not the legend you
have two large public squares
semicircular you see that there's a
church to the west
a market to the east if you look to the
north you will see on the one hand
public baths and a stock exchange and if
you look below the church there's a
structure with a kind of semicircular
auditorium this is actually part of the
university that he is imagining here
it's an auditorium for a medical school
the other thing that's clear as you move
out to the countryside is that he's
mixing old and new structures kind of
neo Palladian villas and old farms old
churches what's happening here is that
the Saltworks the real Salt Works have
generated a vision of an ideal society
it's a utopian gesture representation
comes after the built structure to
generate perfect social world and here
the geometry is what's capturing us all
of its variations the semicircle the
oval the ellipse all of this becomes a
kind of formal metaphor for the harmony
of human existence with nature you can
even evoke the elliptical course of the
planets or think about the economic
metaphor of the circle of production
this is utopia in the deuce terms and so
let's just wrap this up by quoting
LeDoux himself and understanding the
reason for which he looks at the
circular model to generate society this
is Lou do everything is circular in
nature the stone that falls into the
water propagates infinite circles
centripetal force is incessantly
countered by a rotary motion the air the
Seas move in perpetual circles so the
town of show is an immense circle with a
form as pure as that described by the
Sun the line intersecting the diameter
of the Saltworks
crosses the Lu River immense Plains the
town the forest the Geneva Cannell the
Swiss pastures to the left lie the great
rivers the Port of Antwerp and the North
Seas
carry the first and much desired fruits
of our labor Commerce and arts to the
very deserts of Siberia
it's an extraordinary quote and I what I
find most moving in this is the dream of
the global reach of this tiny little
utopia in the countryside which is
generated by a Salt Works Factory and in
this language is this insistence on
geometric forms on nature and on the
rewriting of society so what I'm going
to do now is discuss the repercussions
of all of this but also its sources so I
want to think about the roots of
LeDoux's imagine society by actually
turning back the clock quite a bit going
back to the Renaissance where we see the
visual tradition of utopia emerging in
geometric terms and also in literature
and then I'll sit on the drawings of one
of LeDoux's great contemporaries the
visionary architect
it's yin we brulee who is most often
used to represent architectures
relationship to language in other words
what we call a she dick to appellant or
speaking architecture
you